automobile aéronautique ou encore
ferroviaire style and design travail
pour l'ensemble de ses secteurs
d'activité démonstrateur technologique
maquettes ou encore concept car cette
entreprise fabrique aussi des pièces de
séries limitées comme ceux seuils de
portières automobile et pour parler de
cette société nous sommes avec olivier
meyer bonjour bonjour nicolas
[Musique]
à
alors quel bilan faites-vous de cette
année 2020 écoutez une année un peu
particulière puisque après trois beaux
exercices où nous avions affiché une
croissance organique de 15% ont chaque
année avec deux croissance externe en
2019 là effectivement en 2020 on est
très impactée avec une baisse de 40 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires
un impact important du fait de votre
activité notamment dans le secteur
automobile
oui on travaille dans tous les secteurs
du transport et de gros secteurs sont
très impactées notamment le secteur
aéronautique qui nous avait permis de
faire cette belle croissance notamment
et le secteur automobile qui a été
touché de plein fouet l année dernière
et en quoi vous êtes impact et puis
c'est pourquoi on fait alors écoutez on
intervient sur toute la conception
design des nouveaux intérieurs cabine
sur les sièges business les premières
classes et les compagnies aériennes qui
sont durablement impacté par cette
compagnie reine plus personne ne vole
retarde considérablement leurs
investissements dans les nouveaux avions
dans les nouveaux intérieurs cabine
et puis dans l'automobile c'est pareil
beaucoup de programmes de nos clients
constructeurs ont été décalés face à
l'urgence économique le gouvernement a
déployé plusieurs types dead 3 6 ans les
aides dont vous avez bénéficié alors
nous avons déployé très rapidement les
mesures d'activité partielle les mesures
de décalage des charges sociales nous
avons pris un pg e pour prévoir un peu
l'impact de cette crise sans savoir dès
le mois d'avril qu'elle allait être
évidemment la durée et l'ampleur de
cette crise est
l'entreprise a été très mobilisés les
collaborateurs ont été très très
impliquée pour passer à travers
s'étaient toutes ces difficultés
alors après l'urgence économique a eu la
relance et le plan france relance voilà
vous avez bénéficié de quatre cent
cinquante mille euros de l'état pour un
investissement spécifique absolument
absolument on a candidaté dès le
lancement de l'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt du mois de juillet pour
développer lancer un nouveau programme
nouveau projet de romain va vous parler
qui est très stratégique pour
l'entreprise où on veut profiter entre
guillemets de cette crise pour les
positionner une nouvelle offre plus
agressive plus économique pour les
compagnies aériennes
et vous l'avez dit on va rejoindre
justement romain chareyre votre
directeur design pour nous parler de ce
projet
[Musique]
et avec romain chan nous allons parler
de ce projet roma chareyre bonjour
bonjour nicolas
[Musique]
alors le projet financé par l'état avec
une enveloppe de 450 mille euros en quoi
ça consiste comme olivier l'a expliqué
on doit à la fois gérer aujourd'hui
mandat aussi prévoir demain et donc
investir dans l'innovation pouvoir
propulsé style and design dans une offre
créative qui va intéresser les marchés
donc on est parti de notre expérience et
de notre capitalisation sur les séries
limitées les accessoires pour pouvoir
proposer ça à d'autres domaines dont
principalement le domaine de
l'aéronautique et donc pouvoir offrir
aux compagnies aériennes et aux
opérateurs de l'industrie automne héros
nautique pardon de nouvelles offres de
nouvelles solutions qui s'intéressent
principalement au confort du passager à
la l'image de marque et tout ce qui
concerne le volet comment améliorer la
loyauté réinventer le vol la
personnalisation du véhicule automobile
vous souhaitez l'a transféré pour
personnaliser l'intérieur de l'avion
alors c'est à la fois pouvoir
personnaliser l'intérieur avions et
offrir de nouvelles nouveaux outils de
nouvelles opportunités pour les pour les
compagnies aériennes d'aller chercher de
la chapelle la brand experience c'est à
dire l'image de marque complète de la
compagnie aérienne
mais à la fois aussi pouvoir travailler
sur le confort
amener de la fonctionnalité
supplémentaire
et tout ça ben on espère que ça va
convaincre les compagnies aériennes et
que ça les projettera dans un nouvel
avenir vous allez créer 50 emplois
grâce à cet investissement c'est
l'ambition qu'on a aujourd'hui on est
encore dans des phases d'innovation on
recherche à à comprendre comment notre
innovation peuvent rencontrer le marché
comment elles peuvent amener quelque
chose de nouveau sur le marché et on
espère que demain en développant toutes
ces innovations on doit les gérer en
production doit les gérer en logistique
on doit les gérer en qualité est donc
accompagné son coût en terme de
calendrier
comment ça va se passer alors en termes
de calendrier on a déjà passé notre
première étape 2
conceptualisations aujourd'hui on rentre
dans la phase de discussion avec les
marchés donc ce qu'on souhaite faire
c'est vraiment cette phase de
co-développement co-création on veut pas
avoir raison tout seul on veut que le
marché nous comprenne et nous
soutiennent et donc ça va durer cette
année je pense que à horizon d'un an et
demi deux ans on va pouvoir déployer
notre offre et la rendre concrètes
merci merci mon frère merci